why
was this made what is the limit for
anime a medium that continually pushes
the boundary of Wonder a place that
welcomes all types of stories from all
types of people there's no limit to what
you can see here aside from your own
imagination if you can Envision it it
can get made but like the inventor of a
fart machine in a wind tunnel have we
ever stopped and asked should it get
made into species reviewers worlds and
Harem redo of healer anime has been
pushing degeneracy to a whole new level
in the past few years in a post-redo of
gila World there is little now that
separates anime from hentai every day
the line gets more and more blurry so
the question plaguing Humanity since the
beginning of time is how far can anime
go
ladies and gentlemen I present to you my
life as inukai's dog anime has gone too
far but how could it what could it
possibly do well you see we have now
ventured to a place for which there is
no coming back from tread on the
sanctity of something we should have
never dared touch dogs not genetically
engineered dog girls not fantasy isekai
dog people species not some guy wearing
a dog costume just dogs why did it have
to be dogs what did dogs do to deserve
this man's best friend the purest thing
Mother Earth has gifted us with if
you've ever thought humans don't deserve
dogs here is the evidence to prove that
you are categorically correct this is a
cursed show I probably should have left
to die in obscurity until I had a single
terrifying thought that dwarfed any
existential horror or lovecraftian
nightmare my mind could come up with
somehow somewhere this is gonna be
someone's first anime so to to allow
myself to sleep at night I felt it was
my duty to make a PSA to tell that
person shhh it's okay
it's all right I can't promise that
tomorrow is going to be a better day but
I can promise you that we're going to
get through it together I've committed
to fully talking about this anime but
first I need to talk about today's
sponsor higan yuruthil I've never been
more happy for a sponsor read in my life
in this 3D real-time combat RPG plays a
tasked with reclaiming reality from a
never-ending nightmare like this show
guys maybe the anime man was onto
something who actually needs to watch
anime anymore when you can just play it
higani rutho throws you into its world
and stories that's presented by gorgeous
3D anime s cutscenes with popular voice
actors including yuyogara mamiko norto
Nana Mizuki and more you got some like
Issa an absolute ice queen I can already
tell this girl exudes my energy what
makes me say that
no reason the secret between Issa and
her teammates are in higany ruthville
now let's talk about this gameplay we
have 3D real-time combat high quality 2D
and 3D modeling employing tactics and
bullet time these are just words I don't
need to say anything just have a look at
how beautiful it all comes together with
music that bangs
do I need to say anymore discover the
story behind all these characters start
your adventure with higany Russo today
by clicking the link in the description
to download it and you have a 100 chance
to get the powerful SSR media also you
can use my code in the description to
get my special rewards in higan urethill
thank you very much for sponsoring me
today and with that back
back back to my life as inukai's dog dog
fact number one dogs have 18 muscles to
move their ears in some ways it's
impressive that a show could give a man
who's seen redo of healer who likes
domestic girlfriend who's seen some of
the most degenerate that's come out
of anime the chance to say you know what
I think I have the moral High Ground the
plot goes something like this on some
rainy afternoon a guy wakes up cold and
shivering on the streets how did he get
there what is he doing all questions
that are unimportant because he sees his
classmate and Crush who takes him home
where he comes to the realization to the
precarious situation he's in he is a dog
when I first saw the basic premise of
this I said to myself oh cool some dumb
Slice of Life reincarnation story where
a guy wakes up as a dog I'm a seasoned
isakai fan I've seen worse it can't be
dumber than waking up as a sword or
waking up as a vending machine maybe
they'll tackle the human struggles of
trying to live as a dog maybe the
psychological effects of being stuck in
a dog's body having to navigate a
society made by human having your daily
survival be completely reliant on that
of another human being there's a lot of
places this story could go surely it's
not about a bunch of girls thirsting
over a dog I regret to inform you that
my initial assessment was incorrect
within the first five minutes of taking
the dog home the first thing Karen
unikai decides to do yes her name is
Karen which is very on theme because I'm
about to call the manager is get
undressed in front of the doggo and
bathe with it naked but okay this isn't
too bad there might be some dog owners
who feel comfortable removing their
clothes in front of their dog showering
their dog sucking their dog's nose maybe
this could be wholesome if wholesome was
spelled without a w but it soon becomes
apparent that a feeling towards the dog
are a little devious oh yeah so buried
and devious towards the dog oh yes this
is my coping mechanism you'll see him
right now she takes her dog for a walk
but is feeling a little devious okay
I'll stop now and almost immediately
tries licking the papa if one for some
meddling kids gets way too excited
photographing a dog urinate then
introduces him to a place called coochie
Cove I've seen people dressed up in a
red astronaut suit that are less sus
than this girl right here now if you
think finding out a dog has more risk
than you will ever do is sad don't worry
that's actually one of the least
depressing parts of this show in no
particular order here are some things
depicted in my life as unikai's dog that
involves a girl and a dog bathing naked
tail jobs seductive feet licking getting
a dog to undress you getting a dog to
lick your Chamber of Secrets enticing a
dog with a Chamber of Secrets giving a
dog a ball gag breastfeeding
foreign
[Music]
some of these acts are in the anime some
further on in the manga yes that's right
I read further into the manga don't ask
me what force compelled me to do so
because I still don't know myself maybe
I wanted to see how much worse it could
get maybe I'm learning deep down inside
I have masochistic Tendencies maybe I
was waiting for some divine intervention
because if I could ask a higher power
anything if there was one thing I would
like to know why in God's name is the
art for this manga actually really
good dog fact number two no two
dogs noses are alike many people have
drawn comparison to chainsaw man because
like chainsaw man the dog is named
pochita now chainsaw man's pochita has
joined the short list of the highest
accommodation you can get in an anime
being a good boy pochita that's a good
boy Ein that's a good boy Bond that's a
good boy Nina that's a good girl
inikai's pochita is not a good boy
that's a bad boy bad bad boy one could
argue that in many ways chainsaw man is
just a day in the life of a dog here's
denji who woofs for his owner goes on
walks becomes one with pochita he got
that dog in him then there's a Unico
wolves for their owner goes on walks and
becomes one with pochita because she
does
she got that dog enough you may be
thinking unukai is the outlier here the
freak who loves a dog a little too much
but of course the show had to introduce
a full-on car straight out of the watch
list of your local animal services
there's the tsundere nekotani as your
resident syndrome Ambassador we do not
claim nakotani she can go somewhere else
tinderes can be violent unless
dogs the Shah usagi again
badge she makes the average
player look like a functional member of
society not just limiting it to dogs she
decided to force herself on a poor table
which depressingly adds inanimate
objects to the growing list of things
that have more RIS than weebs do if I
had a dollar for every anime girl I've
seen do unspeakable things to a table
I'd have too which is two dollars richer
than I want to be well unless that's
what you're into I suppose I am the
table then of course completing the
trilogy is the yandere hinukai herself
we can already agree do not stick your
dick in Crazy especially the kind that
this crazy wants what the rest of the
world was asking what the dog doing
inukai was more concerned with who
the dog doing dog fox number three dogs
may be able to oh
oh no no no no no no
devious if by sub Miracle you still
don't know if you should subject
yourself to 12 episodes of this I've
made a simple flowchart for you to
follow first ask yourself do you like
dogs if your answer is no do not watch
this show if your answer is yes do not
watch this show if you're looking for
some kicks in life here are some
alternative suggestions I recommend over
watching My Life As unukai's Dog
skydiving mountain biking ordering the
extra large portion in America tweeting
out chainsaw man is mid setting your
notifications to vibrate then putting
your phone in your pants all
non-dog-related activities that get the
heart pumping this is something that
should be left behind in the bowels of
time in fact as of this very moment I am
working on a time machine so I can go
back and get us back on the right
timeline because what hope is there left
for Humanity knowing that a sentient
human being wrote this then more
sentient human beings made the conscious
decision to green light this into an
anime and throughout that entire long
process not a single person stopped to
ask themselves what in the biblical
have we done on the Day of Reckoning
when Humanity stands before God Almighty
waiting for our final judgment there
standing between us and salvation will
be inukai's dog on that day we will have
to look up at God and tell him that this
is what Humanity has done this is what
mankind has led to the souls of all
humans will beg and plead not to be
forsaken not to be rejected from the
Gates of Heaven but in the end all we
can do is repent and ask for forgiveness
forgiveness from God forgiveness from
each other forgiveness from our dogs
which is more than we deserve
in conclusion I'm a cat person now
[Music]